OREN JACOB: We're chatting
about storytelling
in the age of
conversational interfaces.
My name is Oren Jacob.
I'm the CEO and co-founder of
a company called PullString
that's very happy to be here.
First, thanks to Google
for inviting me here.
Google's home team, other
folks in the speech recognition
team, the folks at API, Google
Cloud, and the various friends
and relatives actually in
Mountain View you work with,
broadly speaking.
In particular, let's get
started with the talk.
There we go.
I work at
pullstring.com, and this
is a picture of the PullString
platform and its authoring
environments.
We'll do two slides
of that PullString
and then 58 slides
about everything else.
But I want to motivate
the talk here,
because this is a professional
platform for computer
conversation, authoring
environments and integrated ML,
hosted runtime,
analytics, collaboration
for text and voice form,
including for Google Home.
So the Didi scale out today
was built in PullString
and live today.
So if you want to
go talk to Didi
and have it sing back
to you what you said,
you can do that with your
new Google Home, the Google
[INAUDIBLE] buddy.
Thank you, Google,
for the nice gifts.
But today's talk, I want to
start a little farther back.
This is Robert McKee.
And Robert McKee wrote a very
fancy book called "Story."
There are some
quotes from it here.
And Robert McKee has
made a career out
of educating people in
the screenplay trade
about how to build characters
and craft dialogue,
broadly speaking.
And we're going to motivate
this talk from that place
and talk about ways
and design motifs.
Challenges and opportunities
when building conversational
interfaces is the
point of today's talk.
This first quote from
McKee, "True character
is revealed in the choices a
human makes under pressure.
The deeper the revelation,
the truer the choice
to the character's
essential nature."
One of the principles
of screenwriting--
and to motivate that for
a second, by the way,
prior to starting
PullString I had spent
20 years working at Pixar.
Anyone see a Pixar
movie in their life?
Raise your hand.
Oh, come on now.
OK.
Whose favorite was
"A Bug's Life?"
No.
OK.
"Nemo," right?
Come on.
Well, we'll talk
more in a second.
Well, one of the things that's
always considered at the studio
that I worked at across
the bay for many years
is under what pressure do
you put the characters that
are in your story?
And at what point
do those characters
make very important decisions?
And the decisions they
make under pressure
is what reveals
through the dialogue
that they use-- that's an
important word for our talk
here about conversational
interfaces--
the dialogue they
use, how they express
what they do under pressure,
and the decisions they make
is how we understand more
about those characters
and where they come from.
Here's McKee's book.
So McKee spent--
I think he's passed away
now-- but 20, 30, 40
years of doing like three-day
long Tony Robbins-style
seminars.
And instead of
spending 2,000 bucks
and go sitting at a
Marriott for three days,
you can buy the book
for like 19 bucks.
And that's good, because McKee
was a very sharp, I'll say,
speaker.
He enjoyed trashing
most of the work
produced in Hollywood,
publicly, in front
of the folks who had done it.
So it was sort of his shtick.
And you pay two grand
for the privilege.
20 bucks is a better deal.
And it includes really 300,
400, or 500 pages of analysis
and advocacy in the space.
I'm going to pick out just
a couple of highlights
from today.
So if you want to do some
good reading afterwards,
you can check that book out.
And you'll find a
lot of the stuff
in here referenced from McKee.
So I want to talk about
three other particular quotes
we'll get started with
here due to the level set.
What it means to review a
character under pressure.
Pressure is essential to the
communication of true character
to audiences.
And if nothing is
at risk, and he
chooses to tell the
truth in a situation
where lying will gain you
nothing, the choice is trivial,
and the moment
expresses nothing.
This is well characterized
as asking the question, hey,
Google Home, what's the
weather in Mountain View today?
We all expect Google
Home to know that,
and it answers the question
with a high of 86 degrees.
Here's the forecast,
high current temperature
being 79, as I discovered at the
Happy Raspberry Pi Integrated
Drink Mixer built by API out
there, which is pretty cool.
I like the peach one myself.
However, if the same
character insists
on telling the truth when a
lie would save their life,
then we sense that honesty
is at the core of his nature.
This is the case when you ask
really any personal assistant,
or really anything in
conversation as a conversation
interface, a question they
might not know the answer to.
You've now placed that
agent, that action, that
bot in an awkward position,
either because they didn't
understand what you
said, so intent was not
recognized properly.
Perhaps earlier in the
pipeline, speech recognition
may abort and give them
something wrong back
to the intent recognizer.
Or ultimately, maybe that's
not a thing within scope.
As demoed by the happy
drink mixer out there
half an hour ago.
I think it was Chris was the
guy demoing, is that right?
So Chris said, hey Google,
what's on the menu today?
And the assistant didn't
know and said I don't know.
And he then went into
the particular thing
they had built,
that new one that
will understand the
menu [INAUDIBLE]
ingredients items,
broadly speaking.
But when you answer--
what you say back is important,
because at that point,
there is pressure.
You pushed the conversation
interface to a place
that the thing you designed does
not know how to accommodate it.
So first, can you understand
what was said back?
And no, you don't
know what to say.
And then how do you defer?
Do you either say I
don't know, politely?
Do you say, bong bong,
checking Wikipedia.
Do you give an answer
and carry it out anyway?
And the choice you make
there, in particular,
in the areas that are out
of scope for the action
that you're designing
are probably
the most important
point in design
that communicates the tone,
mood, and style of what you're
trying to build and how you
expect users and your audience
to feel about the thing
that you're building.
You might expect that--
I'm picking some examples
out of thin air here--
an Uber action,
a Bank of America
action, a Southwest Airlines
action, and a Lyft action
would all answer
quite differently
if you ask them questions
they don't know about,
because the tone, mood,
and style of those brands
and companies are
very different.
And that's what the
talk's about today.
And that's McKee at the end
of one of our story seminars.
There always was a standing
ovation at the end,
because he takes
the last two hours
to tear apart the various plot
lines in "Casablanca," which
is a fun thing to go read.
If you check Google
Images, you can find
the graphs he draws for that.
And at the end of
that two hours,
we all cry and weep with joy.
We've had a story
revealed to us, finally.
Buy a book for 20 bucks
on the way out, please.
Thank you.
See how that plays out.
So moving on past.
Let's define conversation
for a second here.
Sort of scope the talk
more specifically.
I picked off Google
earlier today
an informal exchange
of ideas, spoken words.
More casually, two people
talking back and forth
using natural language.
In computer
conversation, we're going
to swap out one of those
people and swap them
in with a very fancy
computer, Google Cloud being
one of the fanciest
ever built on the planet
Earth today, in fact.
But even if we do that,
we cannot separate having
a conversation from thinking
about whom we're having that
conversation with.
Those things are
inextricably linked,
and they have been
since you were born.
Because everybody you've talked
to-- or, more importantly,
has talked to you--
actually had a personality and
a tone, a mood, and a style.
So here's a quote
you should recognize.
It is not, "Luke, I am your
father," the most misquoted
line in movie history.
It's, "No.
I am your father," for
those nerds in the audience.
"Empire Strikes Back."
There you go.
"No.
I am your father."
There we go.
"To be or not to be."
Act 3, scene 1 of William
Shakespeare's "Hamlet."
Holding the skull.
"I have a dream," by
Dr. King here in DC.
"I'm sorry, Dave.
I can't do that."
Hal.
And "Mommy," which is,
of course, my kids.
So in each one of these cases,
I brought the examples out
both to be very specific,
very general, to be public,
and to be private, to be
fictional, and nonfictional,
to be current and historical
and future tense as well too.
In all circumstances
in these quotes,
I bet you-- who in the audience
recognized the vast majority
of them immediately?
Raise your hands, please.
There we go.
And back at home on livestream,
raise your hands at your desk.
I can't see you.
OK.
That's why I want to explain
to folks here and get
the point across very
strongly that, as you design
the dialogue in
the Google actions
that you build and in the things
you build for Google Assistant,
when you're using
language back and forth,
it is utterly essential
that you contemplate
both intent and content.
Both understanding, which
is an important part of what
we do in the tent here,
and also responding back
and how we design that dialogue.
Because you always associate
what's said with who
says it behind it.
In fact, we learn
about each other
through the use of language.
And we do that at two
levels, both on the surface
and below the surface.
A subtext and a context.
And I use the iceberg
metaphor here sort of bluntly,
because what's said at
the surface in the context
of our conversation is an
important part of what gets
communicated in a conversation.
But all the other
things underneath,
which take different expressions
in text and voice form
add a whole heck of a lot,
if not even the majority,
of your long-term conception
of the experience.
Subtext can be, in
voice form, prosody.
And we're talking super high
really fast or am I going ,
mellow dude.
It means quite different things.
Do I uptick at the back
the way I talk or do I not
and end downbeat?
In text form, it's
how long does the bot
get to respond back and forth?
Do I say typing indicators?
Does the bot make
spelling errors
on purpose or actually
randomly back and forth?
Does the bot
understand leetspeak?
Does the bot understand emoji?
Does it understand animated GIF?
Can it respond back with
emoji, animated GIF, or English
or Spanish or Spanglish?
So North American
normative English
from an AP English test
given in high school
is not what we speak
in messaging platforms
in text or voice form.
It's actually quite different.
And understanding
all the other things
that aren't just the blunt
context around the experience
strongly communicates
to users and audiences
the tone, mood, and style
of what you're building.
Let's go out to the
question of personification.
I'm talking a lot
about characters here,
but we're on the
other hand building
actions for Google Home.
So yes, I worked on this film.
But it happens
also to be the case
that this is the main
theme of every Pixar film
ever made, are things that
aren't human actually talking
back in language back and forth.
Toys talk, fish talk--
I mean, they don't, but
they do in these movies.
And it's actually
quite common for us
to personify all
kinds of things.
That's because we're people,
and when language gets involved,
we've only been talking to
other people with language
since we were all born.
So it makes obvious sense
that if you hear a thing
or see a thing talk
back and forth to you,
you will project human
traits onto that thing.
Your app has a character
and a backstory
and a motivation
tone, mood, and style.
Because everything
you've ever talked
to also does as well too.
If you don't design for that
and deliver it to people,
people will still
assign it to your thing,
whether you want them
to do that or not.
There actually is both
good news and bad news.
There are two
stories to tell here.
On the good side,
personification will help you--
who's a developer themselves?
Raise your hand.
Just a-- really?
Try again.
Who's a developer here?
OK.
Who's actually
built a thing that
involves natural language in
their life in some way, shape,
or form?
Keep your hands up.
Who's here-- and now we're
going to split left-right hand.
Who's done a thing in text?
Oh, text stuff?
And hands for voice stuff.
OK.
Even split.
Personification helps
you in both cases,
because the use of
language will engender
us to assign personal
traits to the thing
that we're engaging with.
And if I do that,
I'm invested in it.
Therefore, I have a hand in
creating that relationship,
whether it's conscious
or unconscious.
That's the benefits to engage
in [INAUDIBLE] tension,
broadly speaking.
On the downside, if you don't
consider that and design for it
very carefully,
you're effectively
going to let your
audience of users
randomly assign the
personality traits they
would like to your particular
app, action, or bot.
And in that case, it's
not clear what they're
going to think about it.
So I would strongly advocate
your being in control of that
as not.
To disregard
character in design is
equivalent to saying letting
the user pick random colors
and button locations
for your GUI.
One of the main differentiating
designs of Google way
back in the day,
which still do today,
thankfully, is the remarkably
simple and direct expression
of Google.com's home page, one
of the gifts to the internet
that is still one of
the joys of web surfing
in general, to the juxtaposition
of all of the other ones that
didn't do that.
They're not here.
You guys still are.
I'm glad to be here with
you, because you guys win
in that regard.
But you certainly
wouldn't want someone
to rescramble the Google Home
page to look all Alta Vista
style.
That's not very helpful
to anybody's cause.
So by asserting the dialogue
that you have in your things
that you write as
well too, you are
doing the equivalent to
button layout, GUI layout,
color palette selection,
responsiveness
designs as well too,
the kinds of feedback,
whether you want
to go skeuomorphic
or not with the interfaces
we build in GUIs.
But different in
voice interfaces.
And while it still
might work, yes, you
could type text into an old Alta
Vista search if you cared to.
As a functional
spec requirement,
I didn't really care.
It turns out none of the rest
of the world did either, too.
So scooting on to foundations
of design and computer
conversation.
A way to think about this,
and also one of the reasons
I started the talk
mentioning Robert McKee,
was you can kind of
think about this space
as interactive screenwriting.
But the trick is, that
for us in this tent,
we're responsible for
lines 1, 3, 5, and 7
but not 2, 4, 6, and 8.
2, 4, 6, and 8 are everything
said back to us by the user.
And interestingly enough,
we have actually no control
at all over those.
That's what's said back to us.
And that's an
important distinction,
because this isn't actually
true in GUI designs.
In GUI designs, you're
asserting what text entry points
you're putting up, what dialog
boxes, what buttons, what
sliders and widgets you have.
In this case, language
is the response back.
And language is a very
unconstrained space.
Part of this craft comes from
traditional screenwriting,
stage writing, theater, prose,
character, story, and dialogue.
The linear narrative arts, and
there's a lot of literature.
I give you only one reference
here to look at in that space.
The other half of this comes
from the art of gaming and web
mobile design and
creating engagement
and retention-- the interactive
arts in those designs.
And this field of crafting
interactive conversation
is one of the unique
blends of these two things.
There are analogies we
can make to some degree.
In the space of
video game design,
whether that's mobile, web,
or a console or desktop
or otherwise, there is a similar
combination to some degree.
But it's just now in
the past 10 or 15 years
that the fields of
interaction design
and the fields of
linear narrative
have begun to cross each other.
And I think in the
space here, particularly
with text and
voice space design,
is one of the most
important expressions
of that new combination
and a fun place to work.
So here are three of the sort
of pretty elemental concepts
to consider as we
go into design here.
One is the concept of fidelity.
And so the related
word here is adjacency.
Computer conversation
always happens
adjacent to real-life
full-fidelity human-to-human
conversation.
If you're talking
to your Google Home,
and it's sitting on
a kitchen counter,
you're probably at breakfast
with your kids and your wife
and husband having a lovely
morning conversation.
And then you're
heckling Google Home
to do a thing for you,
whether it's play music
or control your lights, or
order something as well too.
But it's happening right in
and amongst your family already
talking.
If you're texting back
and forth with a bot,
that's probably happening on
a messaging platform somewhere
or on your phone
where there already
are a billion other folks
texting back and forth with you
who are all actually humans.
So the adjacency
issue is actually
very distinct from
the other things
that I mentioned
earlier on in this talk.
That is not true with
the art of video gaming.
And let me go nerd
out with my Xbox
or play on my Android
phone sitting on BART.
It's not the case
that I was just
playing chess or Rochambeau
with the guy next to me
on BART, probably.
So the game adjacency
issue is quite separated.
I play with my family
Monopoly over here,
and I brought out
my Android phone
and want to play "Clash
of Clans" over there.
But in this case, it probably
is true that I'm texting back
and forth with a billion other
folks who have mobile phones--
sorry, n billion other folks
who have phones out there
in the world--
and my boss engaging me
then, or Google Assistant
is, in text form.
And my Google Home is
sitting in my house.
Also, I'm a nerd,
in my office too.
But let's go to
my house for now.
And at my house, my family is
there speaking back and forth.
That means the bar one
has to reach of adjacency
is actually all of us
talking to each other.
And that's essential
to this field.
That's a super high bar.
There's been a lot of
heckling about [? bosses ?]
past year back and forth.
That's because we're
reaching for human fidelity
conversation, not because--
many people say, like
the public's expectations
were so high.
I think it's just a blunt truth.
It's against all of us
talking to each other.
So we have to
accommodate that need.
And that also speaks,
I think, broadly to
should the things you write
be able to make a joke?
Should they be able
to answer questions
about the topics you're
building for-- travel,
finance, ecommerce,
whatever it is--
or answer the questions
about everything?
I'm going to pick that
last one up for a second.
There's been a theme I've seen
when it comes to text and voice
space work produced
in the space,
that on texting or
talking back and forth
to this particular action,
it should be able to respond
to any question that I asked
and do so in a way that's
quite informative.
But that's not true of
any of us in this tent.
None of us knows everything.
In fact, while Google
doesn't know everything,
at least it organizes it all
for us, which is super helpful.
But it doesn't actually know.
Everything in the
world is not knowable.
So that expectation is unusually
pressed upon actions and bots,
because we don't press it
upon ourselves actually ever.
And if you spoke to someone
who actually knew everything,
I think you've crossed into
some other plane of existence
that I can't describe for us.
That's not true of our reality.
So that also speak--
I use that motivating
case to talk
about specificity of design.
And if you're talking about
an ecommerce experience
or travel or
hospitality or fitness,
and you're building
that for Google Home,
making that be the most
amazing fitness thing
you can talk to you back
and forth seems quite
appropriate to do, but
not answer questions
about geography
or about history,
but find a way to actually
move the conversation back
in the tone, mood, and style
that a fitness instructor would
do to get you back to your
fitness-based actions.
Let's talk about
agency for a second.
So today, I think Kurzweil
may have a different opinion
about this, but synthetic
autonomous emergent personality
today is nowhere close
to human fidelity yet.
It may get there,
in which case I'll
be back here talking to you in
a few years about that agenda.
But that's not true today.
But is that a problem for us?
And I don't think it is today,
because world of fiction--
here's some "Game of
Thrones" cost players
that I found up there.
I like the "Mario" ones
in a previous slide,
as a way to motivate fictional
characters in our daily lives--
suggest that specifically
crafted characters and designed
behaviors can be as
or more effective,
because they've been created
to match the situations
and outcomes we need them for.
Going back to my
fitness example,
just picking that out of thin
air here for Google Home,
any fitness experience
that I'm talking back
to on Google Home will be
designed by maybe someone
in this tent, as opposed to the
actual person at the gym, who
kind of got a parking ticket,
got a decaf coffee by accident
at Starbucks instead of
their caffeine coffee
and was kind of cheesed
off in your spin class,
and brought that attitude
into the class as well too.
And that may not be the
most helpful thing for you
at the time, trying to work
out with your Google Home
as you get back to your kitchen.
I think that if you look
at this slide also too,
a relevant point to make here
is that, going back to earlier
in the talk when I
brought up "Hamlet,"
I threw down a quote
from a thing that's
on the order of 500 years
old, so half a millennium old.
And people all got that.
So the lasting legacy of
character and dialogue
can span, not generations,
millennia of time.
Already does today in
the form of written word
and spoken word and live
theater and stage play.
So the ideas that are presented
when you design a character
and personality can strongly
reach across history
and give you a
sense of the depth
and strength of that
advocacy in our design work.
And I had to throw up
[INAUDIBLE] doing cosplay here
as a motivating case.
That's a lot of Stormtroopers.
And it turns out they
actually formed a brigade
and walked around themselves.
They spend about as
much time doing this
as people in the
military reserve
do here in this
country, it turns out.
And while I support "Star
Wars" and maybe our US military
as well, and then for
Lucasfilm on this one,
because that's pretty
cool they do that.
All right.
So on to creativity.
Am I a computer scientist
or should I become one?
Or am I a writer and
should I become one?
Both of these are highly
creative pursuits,
but with different emphases.
So it depends on what
you're trying to do.
There are many
things that are built
in the space of the
computer conversation that
are transactional-based.
In ecommerce, banking and
fund transfers as well too,
and those things
are very efficient
and compact expressions.
There are also
things that are built
that have much more sort
of poetic intentions.
Interactive fiction, broadly
speaking, mysteries, romance.
The genres of literature also
can be expressed this way
as well too.
And in between kind of
exists everything else.
Deciding who is
writing your dialogue
and who's thinking about your
dialogue design, I think,
should be motivated by
those cases back and forth.
But the spectrum
exists in this field,
and I want to talk about
celebrating both sides
of this the rest of this talk.
"Creativity is just connecting
things," from Steve.
I had to throw that quote
down here for us today.
So three topics in particular,
getting specifically
to designing of
actions directly,
and voice space skills in
content, intent, and context.
Keyboard, mice, and
touchscreens are all examples
of high precision,
high accuracy,
and unambiguous inputs.
Was the button pressed or not?
But they have a
very small aperture.
Got a button click,
got a key press.
Language is hugely imprecise,
terribly inaccurate,
utterly ambiguous, and has
a near infinite aperture.
But it can be
shockingly efficient.
And it's in this juxtaposition
here that the most important
difference is about how
we design has sort of come
to surface now.
I brought up the words
love and hate here
for a second, because in
four characters, both sides,
nations go to war,
peace treaties
are signed, humanity
advances itself
at a level of just
four simple characters,
also with a bracket and
a slash as well, too.
It's impossible to express
that in a GUI interface.
With a voice and
language interface,
you can, and you can get to
all things like awkward here.
I've got a picture of
a monkey's face here.
The concept of awkwardness is
a very interesting proposition,
because it presupposes
you understand
what the monkey and the
face should have been doing.
Why does it look funny
or sarcastic to you
as it relates to other
faces that you've seen
with goofy smiles in selfies?
It's all a set of
information encapsulated
in that word next to that image.
We invented language,
in fact, to communicate
the human condition in all
of its complexity, ambiguity,
and subtlety.
And so the design
principles themselves now
and practices that
help us handle
this in a medium whose
boundaries are [INAUDIBLE]
include content and intent.
Intent recognition,
as we all know,
is a thing that many people
focused on in this field,
including Google with API
[INAUDIBLE] offerings,
and other places in the
Google network of things.
And that's good.
That's understanding what's
said inbound to us by user.
And I do celebrate that,
but it's half the problem.
The other half of the problem is
content, which is as important
and requires equal attention
from both our tools
and our processes on both sides.
If you're looking at
the amount of effort
put into building an
action for Google Home,
and you have a 10-week
project to work on,
10 person weeks to assign to it,
if you're spending eight person
weeks designing your intents
and three days writing
dialog and then
debugging, you've
not spent your
resources in a way that
represents what the
design requirements really
are of the project.
Those two things
are actually almost
bang on even money,
broadly speaking,
because half of a
conversation is understanding
what you say to me.
And the other half
is me answering back
to you in response back.
You have to handle both
of those things evenly.
I think as an industry,
we way over-index
on intent recognition.
I understand why.
That's a problem computer
scientists are very well
schooled to go solve.
That makes perfectly
reasonable sense.
It's also a thing we
didn't have before.
So we had to go build.
Machine learn recognize intent.
And that's great.
We have those and
they're advancing now,
going forward day by day.
As a field that
produces work now
in the space for audiences
and users to use and engage,
contemplating both
what's understood
and what's said back
with even measure
is an advocacy I want to
bring to you guys today.
Iteration and creative control.
Iteration time enables creative
expressivity and reach.
How efficiently
can I do a thing?
The faster I do it, the
better I can make it.
The background of the
slide I chose specifically
because this is
a gesture drawing
agenda done by a woman, Elaine
[? Horry, ?] I found online--
license to be used here
for you guys to see--
and was done in a session
often sitting down with a model
and drawing various
gestures in these styles.
So who here has a
guess for how long
it took her to do
that many drawings?
Throw a number out.
AUDIENCE: 20 minutes.
OREN JACOB: 20
minutes over here.
I hear a week over there.
Just a couple days.
These are probably
done, I'm guessing,
at about 30 seconds
to one minute
per, broadly speaking,
typically a lunch session is
done at the studio,
where you're drawing
as fast and rapidly as you can.
And one of the
reasons why, if you're
going to spend four years
making an animated film,
you want to nerd out at
lunch drawing rapidly,
is you can iterate through
dozens and dozens of poses
for a character in the
course of a two-hour span
before you spend the time to
dental floss it in the film,
finally, as from
my previous life.
In this slide here,
how long does it
take me to debug my bot?
Why did the thing answer
back the way it did
and what is it saying next?
Oh, I have to go build a thing
and recompile it and push it
out to the cloud and
carry on as well too.
Or can I see it live in where
I'm working right now today?
The time it takes
you as a developer
out there to run a full loop
to understand what broke
and how to fix
it, as we all know
from being software developers,
is an essential contributor
to our efficiency in that area.
So I want to push that forward
here in this basic computer
conversation that it's
not just how fast I'm
going to design my intent.
It's not just how fast
I can write my dialogue.
It's when I have the thing
stood up and running,
and I'm chatting
back and forth a bit
or talking back and forth to
it, how long in clock time
is the actual loop
from it saying
a thing I didn't want it
to say to me fixing it
and saying it the
right way next time?
Measure that on
the clock, and when
you're down from eight hours
to one hour to 15 minutes
to a minute to actual
real-time, you've
watched yourself from
a year-long project
to a due deadline
project as well.
More importantly, though,
than the budget implications
are if you're at a
place where in real time
you're editing and
working and fixing things,
you're then going to
start experimenting.
You're then going to start
playing with the thing.
And you're going to find what
you can achieve in conversation
will then expand significantly
beyond a graph [INAUDIBLE]
connected, a very simple diagram
of say this, then go this, then
go here.
Well, I'll start there,
but because language
is so expressive, our
users do this to us anyway.
So it's an important way to
think about the tool steps
that you use and the
process you bring
to bear to measure
the efficiency of it
and how fast you can
fix and adapt things.
Predictability is a
critical design agenda here
as well, too.
Often we're asked to throw
more data at machine learn
and intent recognizers,
because they'll get better.
Well, for the
folks in this room,
I bet you probably
understand what that means.
But a lot of the rest
of the world might not.
And in particular,
what data and how much?
And if I did that,
how would it change?
Linearity isn't the
requirement here.
Predictability is.
And I think that as many more
folks out there become educated
about the techniques of machine
learn intent recognition,
broadly speaking, folks
beyond just this tent
will get better and be able
to do this in the wild.
But today this is
a real struggle
for a lot of folks
and developers
who aren't at Google,
but are outside
doing their own things
in computer conversation,
in text or voice form.
For them, to improve their
machine learn intent,
broadly speaking, is a challenge
I share with you-- we all share
as an industry-- to
help us understand
how to better work with things.
I use the idea of
a black box here.
You never want a black
box in a creative agenda.
I have a picture of a
bike here on purpose.
So who here knows
how to ride a bike?
All hands should go up.
Yeah.
OK.
If I'm on a bike, and I
stand off and take my hand
on the seat, and I shove
the bike down the street,
what does the bike do?
Anybody?
Does it fall over?
Immediately?
No.
It will soar for
some period of time
and doing kind of
this-- whoa whoa whoa.
And then it will cliff out.
Who here can explain
to me the physics
behind how that actually works
in a closed-form solution?
Anybody?
No.
It's actually not describable
by modern mechanics today
in a closed-form
solution, interestingly.
But yet, you all
raised your hands
because you can ride a bike.
A bike is a remarkably nonlinear
mechanical dynamic mechanism.
We in our minds
have all understood
how to lean, reverse back,
adjust the handlebar,
and correct against the steer
to get the lean over to get
the bike to turn, even though
no physics professor at Cal
or Standford could whiteboard
out how that actually
works in a closed-form
solution today.
So a good example
from all of our lives,
including my young kids' lives,
about the human mind's ability
to map a predictable
very complex system
and work with it
very, very creatively,
even though it's not linear.
And now I'm going to tie
this together with context.
This word is like super
over-used in this space.
So I'm going to try to talk
about this a little bit
quite directly here.
First, at a high level, context
is the mental scaffolding
that we and our technology need
to help us manage complexity.
Hence the Pantheon in the back
getting rebuilt for you there.
Conversation, broadly speaking,
is a piecewise linear agenda.
If I'm going to negotiate
with you about a pizza order
back and forth for a
few minutes and then
about my commute
home on BART and then
about what I'm doing this
weekend, going to Tahoe or not,
back and forth, each one of our
pizza discussions and our BART
discussions was locally
two, three, or four
turns about pizza and
then BART and then Tahoe.
And notice that was pizza, BART,
and Tahoe is not connected.
Those small piecewise linear
bits that connect together,
we can take large
advantage of, because when
I'm talking about pizza, and
nerding out about mozzarella
versus pepperoni, and I'm having
that discussion about pizza
ordering agendas, not about
what the guy next to me
was eating on the BART
train, which I could
be saying in the next agenda.
I don't think we take
advantage of this enough.
And I say this because
a lot of systems
today built offer giant
long flat lists of intents
to recognize, broadly
speaking, and don't
use where you are in the
context of the conversation
to motivate intent recognition
and to motivate dialogue
going back and forth.
That's true in how
you build things.
It's true in our toolsets.
As a field, in
general, you can only
pull this off if you combine
content and intent together,
not keep them
separated far apart.
But brought together,
it lets the folks
who build actions and bots
and other things as well
work with both of those
things back and forth
in and amongst each other as you
blend and create in the space
together.
It's one of the most important
points of this talk here.
So I tie this down now as we
get to a few minutes for Q&A
at the end here.
I'll talk about, one, having
gone through all that,
I'll leave you with the
following conundrum.
And my favorite rock 'em,
sock 'em slide, which
I had to throw in there too.
The more personality that
you offer in a thing,
the more you'll engage
and delight your users,
broadly speaking, and
the more memorable
you will be long term.
At the same time, more
personality that you offer,
the more you polarize and
segment your audience.
Without mentioning names,
if you participated
in the last US
presidential election,
there were two candidates
who, broadly speaking,
move the country
into two places.
I don't think anybody
in this country
wanted to vote for both
of them simultaneously.
That would make little sense.
That's why there
were two candidates.
I won't go any farther
than that, but as
an example of if you went
that far with personality,
you actually chopped your
audience bang-on in half.
Now, that's not a thing a
company like Google can do.
You're trying to reach
everybody in the world.
And, of course, me and some
awesome rad action developer
wants the biggest
audience I can get.
So therefore, should I withdraw
and not do any personality
to maintain a giant audience?
Well, if I built a thing
that appealed to absolutely
everybody, it would
be the definition
of the most average thing in the
world, which actually is boring
to everybody as well, too.
Google is not taking
that position.
Your home page is
not a boring design.
It's actually quite
a bang-on crisp one
and it has been now, again,
for going on nearly two decades
now, to your credit.
So what do we do?
Do we go all-in Darth Vader and
go full personality or all-in
plain vanilla and do
nothing as well too?
And that is the
art of the space.
That's a judgment call.
But I won't leave you with
just a hanging I don't know.
There's no right answer here.
But as a thought, creating
one average personality,
I don't think, is likely a
path to the right answer.
My best suggestion is to
consider a countable plurality
of personalities to get a
good match for the over 95%
cases of potential audiences.
In the case above, if you just
built the average personality,
for any individual user
when something more
funny or appealing shows up--
perhaps Samuel Jackson is
doing the voice of your banking
app for your Capital One.
I could imagine that happening.
People who like
Samuel Jackson will
go and be attracted to that
and be pulled off the average.
The average sitting
in the middle
is susceptible to any one of
the particulars being better,
and that plurality
will be them over time.
But you can't write a
personality for all of them.
That would be uncountable
number of personalities.
So I think the answer probably
plays out here to a countable
plurality to meet the largest
audience that could get
to a 95%-plus case of coverage
of appeal, broadly speaking,
to a general global audience.
Parting shot for two minutes,
your questions coming up here,
is that you can check
out pullstring.com
if you want to work
with a system that
offers those things together.
It's what we're trying to build
here at PullString and doing
that with Google.
And thanks for your
help in that regard too.
And if you want to build some
awesome actions for Google
Home, you can start that
like this afternoon.
People [INAUDIBLE] to do that.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]